heute nacht um 132 wird eine falcon 9
rakete mit einer ganz besonderen fracht
gestartet eine neue phase der alien
suche startet wenn der nasa satellit ins
all geschickte test steht dabei für
trading exoplanet service satellite also
satellit zur untersuchung vorbeiziehen
der exoplaneten sein vorgänger keppler
über den aber ja oft berichtet der geht
in rente und es wird ihn ersetzen mit
viel spannenderen leistungsdaten ja also
ob er jetzt schneller aliens finden
werden unser thema jetzt den klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen
der weltraum teleskop kepler geht in
rente im geht der treibstoff aus um sich
korrekt auf die zu untersuchenden sterne
auszurichten und in andere richtungen
wiederum auf die erde um die gewonnenen
daten zu übermitteln kepler hat bis
heute unglaubliches geleistet die
entdeckung der mehrheit der exoplaneten
geht auf sein konto 2500 stück der
absolute wahnsinn jetzt aber noch
getoppt wird es hat nämlich deutlich
verbesserte leistungsdaten und eine
veränderte mission zum einen sucht nicht
kleine ausschnitte des himmels ab
sondern hat eine 350 mal größer
beobachtungs fläche als keppler das alte
weltraumteleskop suchte den himmel ja
stück für stück ab und dabei ist das ja
alles wirklich ein wenig verblüffend
dass das exo planeten gibt das wissen
wir erst seit den 90er jahren vorher gab
es keine methoden um sie aufzuspüren
mit der entdeckung von drei planeten die
um den puls aps r 12 57 +12 kreisen
durch den polnischen astronomen
alexander wolf wurde das 1992 anlass der
pulsa pulse nämlich unregelmäßig da
planeten sein strahlt blockierten durch
die genaue bestimmung dieser
unregelmäßigkeiten konnten drei planeten
entdeckt werden das waren damit die
ersten planeten die zweifelsfrei
existierten und 1995 wurde dann der
erste planet entdeckt er um einen stern
ähnlich unserer sonne kreist planet 51
pegasi b kreis um einen stern im
sternbild pegasus seine entdecker hatten
festgestellt dass der stern 51 pegasi im
all herum feiert verursacht durch einen
planeten der um ihn kreist anhand der
stärke dieses 1 konnten sie sogar die
größe des planeten errechnen 0,46
jupitermassen so langsam kamen die
planeten suche in fahrt jetzt ging es
darum planeten aufzuspüren die erd-
ähnlich sind und damit leben ermöglichen
das war wie die nadel im heuhaufen zu
suchen die meisten planeten waren zu
heiß zu kalt zu klein zu groß es gab
kein wasser auf ihn oder sie kreisten
zudem zentral gestellt doch in den
letzten jahren wurden immer mehr
planeten entdeckt und damit auch immer
mehr auf denen leben möglich ist eine
bedingung ist ja die entfernung der
planeten zum stern um den sieg reisen
sie müssen sie in der goldlöckchen zone
die heißt tatsächlich so der habitablen
zone befinden benannt ist diese zone
nach dem märchen über das goldlöckchen
das erst zu heißen brei ist dann zu
kalten und dann breit er richtig
temperiert ist denn das ist die
wichtigste bedingung es darf auf dem
planeten nicht so heiß und nicht zu kalt
sein damit leben entstehen kann aber es
gibt planeten auf denen diese
bedingungen gelten und auf denen sogar
ausreichend wasser vorhanden ist doch
das sind nur sehr wenige dies 12 14 b
ist einer von ihnen und vielleicht
derjenige mit den besten bekannten
lebensbedingungen er hat den richtigen
abstand zum zentralgestirn einem roten
zwerg einem kleinen nicht sehr heißen
stern und blies 12 14 b verfügt über
eine atmosphäre mit einer menge
wasserdampf hier sind die chancen am
größten dass es leben dort existieren
könnte allerdings ist mit 12 14
rund 40 lichtjahre von uns entfernt für
uns zur zeit unerreichbar ja und es
wurden ja immer mehr solcher planeten
entdeckt zuletzt das treppchen system
mit sogar sieben exoplaneten von denen
drei in der habitablen zone liegen mit
heutigen stand sind 3765 exoplaneten
entdeckt worden und mit tests soll diese
zahl deutlich höher werden es wird
200.000 sterne untersuchen die möglichst
nah an der erde liegen und wird so mit
dem transit verfahren besser schneller
und damit wahrscheinlich viel mehr
exoplaneten finden
bei diesem verfahren wird ja untersucht
ob und wie stark und wie regelmäßig
sternen sich verdunkeln daraus kann ganz
einfach errechnet werden wie groß und in
welcher entfernung um die welcher
geschwindigkeit planeten an den
jeweiligen sternen vorbeizieht und damit
auch in abhängigkeit von der stern
klasse und der größe des zentralgestirns
ob sie in der habitablen zone liegen und
damit leben auf ihnen existieren könnte
und das geht jetzt ganz schnell los in
zwei monaten ist es auf position und
dann startet die mission die es zunächst
auf zwei jahre begrenzt bis dann
hoffentlich endlich der x-fach
verschobene start des james webb
weltraumteleskop stattfindet dann geht
es nämlich wirklich ab und wir haben
eine riesen-chance spuren von leben zu
finden wenn er als erstes neues zum
thema alien suche und zu allen anderen
themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
und so brüssel
ich noch ein kleines geschenk für euch
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der genau glocke
vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür
auch draufklicken außerirdisches leben
an viel mehr orten möglich da geht es um
die these dass sie vielleicht nicht
unbedingt in der habitablen zone liegen
müssen also ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran